all right cynical low energy Jeremy
today but that's what you get when I get
ripped away from my Warhammer Miniatures
to talk about garbage but we're all here
so let's talk about it
so when city is
The Red Door
I was so close a few years ago if this
movie makes money there will be a fifth
Insidious movie called the final key or
the final door or something almost but
for insidious The Red Door
the kid can I get I don't don't make me
look it up his name is the kid the kid
from Insidious is all grown up he's
going to college now it's a liberal arts
college which means while he's working
towards his goal of being a Starbucks
barista with an insane amount of debt he
gets to be inundated with creepy imagery
all for the sake of forced fifth
installments who's excited are you
excited either way thank you for
clicking on this video I do appreciate
it do you need to watch the previous
Insidious movie no you don't does it
even tie into it I don't remember but
now you're safe not watching it or
watching it and forgetting you watched
it like the rest of us did anyhow he's
in college he and his dad Patrick Wilson
been hypnotized to forget the traumatic
events of yesteryear so now he has all
these cloudy memories coming back creepy
imagery coming to him he's painting
really eerie [__] in his art class and
his dorm room his dorm room in which his
roommate is a girl I just found it weird
that she was like hey I talked to the
office I said they'd clear it up but
they said to crash here in the meantime
I don't know I just feel like someone in
office administration would just get
fired for that yes ma'am you have a mail
roommate who fits serial killer profile
to a team and paints really creepy
imagery in the dorm room
but could you crash there for the night
it's kind of a hassle so he gets to
Spirit walk in the dollar store upside
down there are demons there's a red door
also there's a lot of college angstiness
the case of Insidious though is really
curious one because it started out
feeling like horror and now it feels
like how to phrase it interdimensional
Thriller elements ever since Patrick
Wilson was going through the spectral
realm like he's razziel or some [__]
it's like they were like hey that's
really cool let's lean into that more
than horror it has some interesting
imagery elements and parts but it's
nothing you haven't seen a billion times
before and even then it doesn't
organically go anywhere it's usually
some blurry figure across the street
through the window It's like because
he's having memory problems like oh hey
do that thing you know like classic
concentration you gotta remember where
the images were that you flipped over
and then you got to match them up memory
game he has all these cardboard images
on his window I'm like dude I respect
the Arts and Crafts element but
seriously you don't have a switch that
game is is in Mario 3 just do it there
or it's online what year does this take
place if I Google that game right now I
will be able to find it but if you do
that you can't have the camera focusing
on the window in which you see this
blurry figure from across the street
supposed to be creepy but it's not
creepy it just comes across like someone
had an idea for one moment one shot one
element one image and someone else was
like yeah that's great
to what end what why is it what are we
doing after that why are we doing it at
all I don't know shut up just it thought
it sounded cool just comes across like
hey you know what I really like is this
picture of the dude what a great picture
anyhow maybe I'll hang it up over there
and maybe I won't I don't know I feel
like he's my spirit animal tell you who
I did like Sinclair Daniel who played
his roommate slash friends I thought she
was great granted she feels like she has
walked into another movie entirely her
spirit her zest her spunkiness kind of
took me out of the horror movie elements
then I remember there are no real
effective horror movie elements so [__]
it you do you you have fun I feel like
that's what she did I feel like she got
the script she was like are you kidding
me
I'm having fun with this I'm going to do
my thing I don't know I don't know if
Patrick Wilson made that call or if she
did in spite of the whole situation
Patrick Wilson he directed this movie
it's his big screen directorial debut I
feel like that's kind of important
information I saw his name on the
credits I was like oh that's surprising
on with the show guys in the end I was
over Insidious by the time the last
movie came out and I'm over it still we
all knew they were gonna keep it going
but this movie shows why they definitely
should not or if you're gonna bring
Insidious back have it feel scarier have
it feel more like horror the attempts at
horror are just really boring cliches
you've seen a million times before the
rest of the movie feels like it's trying
to be a cooler Spirit realm traversal
spectral realm travel suspense thriller
wedged in between really boring angsty
College [__] maybe if you're so invested
in the Insidious story the story of the
family that you're just like I have to
see the next chapter what would happen
if the kid goes to college I need to see
but for me now I can remember in T minus
one day yep already forgot all right so
Insidious The Red Door have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]